well i don't trust red wings you hold on
a minute you don't have to trust red wig
but i'm gonna go see if he's right cause
i have a feeling they might be a part of
the big three
what big three the big three white big
three androids aliens and wizards
that's not a thing that's definitely no
it's not every time we fight we fight
one of the three so who are you fighting
now gandalf yep
how do you know about gandalf i read the
hobbit in 1937
when it first came out so you see my
point no i don't there are no wizards
dr strange is a sorcerer
a sorcerer is a wizard without a hat
think about it right i'm right i just i
just came up with that it's crazy
look that's not the point these guys
aren't magical all right they use brute
force just like you
the incredibly annoying guy in front of
me with the staring problem i'm coming
with you no you're not
one minute two drop offset
so what's our plan
great so no plan
30 seconds enjoy your ride buck no you
can't call me that
why not that's what steve called you
steve knew me longer and steve had a
plan
15 seconds to drop i have
a plan really
what is it
so what's our plan buck
i have a plan
oh and i have all of that on camera
great
exclusively on disney plus
these guys use brute force they're
strong
too strong then they might be a part of
the big three what big threat
androids aliens and wizards that's not a
thing that's definitely
no it's not
there are no wizards dr schrein is a
sorcerer a sorcerer is a wizard without
a hat
original series streaming march 19th
exclusively on disney plus
our country is vulnerable
we need new heroes
let's get to work
we're not a team nope
or partners
co-workers
we look damn good
streaming march 19th exclusively on
disney plus
the world's upside down right now
where do we start
superheroes that cannot be allowed
people to exist they need a cat
damn right
original series streaming march 19th
exclusively on disney plus
[Music]
the legacy of that shield is
complicated
[Music]
the world
it's upside down
people need something to get behind
[Music]
they need the symbol
so what's our plan
so no plan
great
[Music]
what's going on in that cyborg brain of
yours you don't want to know
oh yeah i can see it working gear's
turning
oh they're malfunctioning they're on
fire
you